الأمين العام لحزب العمال الكوري الساعة الثانية ميوهو تشوسون
رئيس وزارة الخارجية بجمهورية كوريا الديمقراطية الشعبية
أين الرفيق كيم سيونغ هون خادم الله؟
تقع في جمهورية صباح بما يكفي
2nd 3rd أي مايو 9 سبتمبر الازدهار
ابحث واكتب سوزان صن كونفوشيوس
خلف اللجنة المركزية المهزومة ، هناك حشد من الغوغاء في الدائرة السياسية
متى ومتى تكون عضوا باللجنة المركزية للغرفة
سكرتير منظمتنا ، فاز 000 لدينا بالتوقف عن اللعب
الدائرة السياسية في اللجنة المركزية للجنة المركزية لحزب العمل
3 إذا كان الغوغاء هو القائم بأعمال المفوض ، فقم بتنظيم مجلس الوزراء
عبء الشعب ، وزن العدو ، جريمة حزب العمال الكوري
عضو اللجنة الدائمة للمكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية
وبارك جونغ تشون ، سكرتير الأداء المركزي للغرفة.
مسؤولو الحزب والحكومة الذين باعوا التعليق للصحفيين
شارك هنا
سيقدم لك العمال المسؤولون عن وكالة afterglow
شارك
عظمة تلقي إشعار حي وعظيم
صورة Hyeongjo طوال اليوم عند التمثال
مكان للاحتفاظ بممارسة محايدة للتنظيف
أصبح مكانًا للركوب مع المشاركين
جنبا إلى جنب مع القائد العظيم والشانجبي العظيم
بمناسبة أول رئيس وزراء يبحث عن رعاية طبية
لا
[موسيقى]